good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-4516
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
all entrances to
scp-4516 have been shielded with
thamaturgic warding personnel are to
maintain these wards indefinitely
under no circumstances are personnel to
enter scp-4516
unless the majority of the l5 council
are in agreement
all objects and entities extracted from
scp-4516 are to be kept in containment
indefinitely research of class 2
anomalous objects or lower is permitted
with the written permission of the site
director anomalous objects above class 2
require written permission from the
regional director
non-sapient biological entities are to
be sterilized and maintained until their
death after which the body is to be
incinerated after study sapiens are to
be naturalized in terrestrial law and
relocated to various anomalous enclaves
should they have no criminal record are
not infected with a contagious illness
and are not connected to sorks's nations
monetarily militarily or religiously
description
scp-4516 is a series of four gateways to
an unknown location believed to be
somewhere within the milky way galaxy
these gateways are located in iraq
scp-4516
north korea scp-4516-2
the bahamas scp-4516-3
and the united kingdom scp-4516-4
upon entering an instance of scp-4516
the individual will experience symptoms
typical of long-distance gateway travel
including nausea dizziness ringing in
the ears bleeding from the gums etc the
exit point is always the same regardless
of instance entered this appears to be a
large forest filled with trees of an
unknown species travel through the
gateway from the other side takes the
individual to the original gateway from
which they entered native entities are
sent to a random destination unless they
are in physical contact with one another
the exit point has been designated
scp-4516
a
scp-456
is the interior of a dyson sphere
indicated by the binary stars in the
middle of the sky and the curved nature
of the world allowing one to view the
perceived top of the sphere from the
bottom a gravitational anomaly pervades
the entire structure making objects
behave as they would on earth negating
these centrifugal forces it is estimated
that the dyson sphere has a roughly 16
light-minute
287 million 800 000 kilometer diameter
the atmospheric composition of scp-4516a
is similar to earth albeit with slightly
higher levels of neon and lower levels
of argon than baseline it should also be
noted that scp-4516a
is anomalously stable showing no signs
of orbital decay or seasons related to
an area's distance from the sun
scp-4516b possesses a noticeably
elevated thamaturgical inclination than
earth making spells and naturally
occurring anomalous abilities much
stronger in scp-4516b
than on baseline earth
the reverse is also true as organisms
and spells native to scp-4516b
have less thaumaturgical prowess on
earth than they do in scp-4516b
scp-4516b possesses an extremely
extensive and varied biosphere with an
estimated 1.3 times 10 to the power of
16 indigenous species although the
accuracy of this estimate is presently
uncertain an estimated 87 percent of all
species display some sort of
thaumaturgical ability ranging from
teleportation to chronological
displacement the remaining 13 percent of
life forms that do not display
thaumaturgical abilities are highly
specialized life forms that are limited
to specific environments typically the
deep ocean or highly isolated islands
to date the architects of scp-4516
are unknown numerous sapient species and
a handful of deities have been
discovered although it is believed that
these naturally evolved on scp-4516b
and not the builders of the structure
discovery
scp-4516 was discovered after a group of
large humanoid mammalian beings appeared
spontaneously in the bahamas on november
30th
1945. these entities measured 7 meters
in height with green dark skin a single
eye and were armed with crossbows and
swords these entities were intercepted
by the global occult coalition and
destroyed before the foundation was
aware of the incident
the event was classified as an anomalous
incident until an identical event
occurred on july 9 1948 in north korea
foundation assets were alerted in time
and containment is established with a
single foundation fatality upon
interrogation
scp-4516b was discovered in addition to
scp-4516-1
3 and 4 based on foundation records of
similar incidents
the entities collectively classified as
scp-4516-1
were each individually interrogated and
revealed to be colonists from torak a
city-state within scp-4516
and were attempting to escape
persecution for their religious beliefs
contact with the entity's government was
established and exploration of scp-4516
began the humanoids were naturalized in
terrestrial law and relocated to various
anomalous enclaves
including three portlands the species
numbers in the 60 thousands according to
the 2017 census
incident 4516 won
after years of negotiation with the
commonwealth of torak the state was
overtaken by the nearby nation of
farathia due to a combination of border
disputes religious disagreements and
catalyzed by an assassination attempt on
the tarakian queen's favorite concubine
the nation of farathia was much more
hostile towards the foundation than the
original tarakian government this is
best shown through the infiltration of
the foundation by a farathian agent whom
is responsible for a containment breach
on site 16 resulting in the death of 892
foundation personnel and 36 civilians
following this the foundation was
temporarily cut off from scp-4516-1
isolating personnel on the interior from
earth
after three months of no contact the
gateways were reopened foundation assets
previously trapped within scp-4516-1
had apparently worked with baratheon
rebels and overthrown their rule
re-establishing the nation of torak the
nation of forathia was destroyed in the
conflict personnel involved were given
the foundation gold star for valor
exploration of scp-4516-1
continues
incident 45-16
2. through exploration of scp-4516b
a city-state under the name of
minnetarius is encountered measuring 18
kilometers wide minnetarius is inhabited
by a species of cat-like quadrupeds
measuring two meters at the shoulder
this species is telekinetic and are able
to use a very limited form of
thaumaturgy
upon contact the inhabitants of the
city-state had an abrupt socio-religious
shift
foundation personnel apparently
resembled the inhabitants version of
angels and thus believed the foundation
to be holy beings
this quickly degraded however once the
inhabitants realized that foundation
personnel have red blood
when their angels bleed purple when
injured this led to a brief civil war
before a massive assault against
foundation forces the inhabitants
believing them to be demons and wishing
the apocalypse upon them
sixty-five percent of personnel did not
survive the remaining thirty-five
percent were forced to retreat into
torak a siege ensued which negatively
affected the relationship between the
foundation
and torak
incident 4516
3
torak after 19 months of siege is
finally overrun after a tunnel
constructed by the mintarians opens up
near the center of the city-state a mass
slaughter ensues resulting in nearly 100
casualties among foundation and
terrakian forces the gateway is sealed
immediately to date there has been 17
incursions from the other side of
scp-4516
each of which has been successfully
repelled
incident 4516
four
after three years of inactivity from the
exit point a foundation strike force was
authorized to enter in order to assert
the current situation in scp-4516b
it was quickly ascertained that the
forest previously surrounding the exit
point had been converted into a new
nation called the memorthian empire this
nation is very technologically socially
and thumaturgically advanced
the conflict between the mintarians and
tarakians was determined according to
historical records to have spilled out
into the surrounding area
and civilizations
enveloping the entire region into a
brutal series of wars
and unstable alliances along with
religious species and ethnic purges
this culminated in a single war between
three different alliances the gornak
union the sorces and morinian
confederacy the gornok union was a
collection of highly authoritarian
theocratic states the sarxis was a
collection of very secular and
collectivist nations and the mourinho
confederacy was an ideologically diverse
group of nations which would be too weak
to otherwise defend themselves
rapidly advancing technology and
thaumaturgy which was aided by
technology and other materials left
behind by foundation personnel in the
years prior ultimately allowed a joint
gornok and marinian force to destroy the
sorksus alliance this however has led to
a military standoff between theocratic
states and the increasingly libertarian
miranian states with terrorist attacks
perpetrated by sorksus-backed groups
against mourinho nations becoming
increasingly common as is immigration
from these nations
[Music]
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to tomothy
anvil
zargaron
professor puffer
nobody
will remember vino
gevios the hollow
zazipan
jordan c wilde
lamke
dr briggs
tailored printers
[Music]
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
lost boy
a real american hebrew
the morrigan
james sabha
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash the vulcan
thank you
you